we are not going to spend time on the
apocalypse today no no we're going to
spend time on childhood which is like
it's the opposite of the apocalypse it's
actually a hedge against apocalypse
that's what childhood is in some ways um
and we're going to start so this is um
as as regular
listeners will know we are going chapter
by chapter through our our book a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century which is coming out september
14th 2021
and uh doing an excerpt or two from each
of the successive chapters and then
talking about it and so i actually have
a couple of excerpts for this week um
that i'm going to read we're going to
talk about and then i have some other
some other supporting
information to
to share so without further ado we're
going to start with just the first three
pages of the childhood chapter it's a
it's a
all of these chapters really um go so
many places and so even if you feel like
oh you're reading excerpts i pretty much
know what's in the book no every single
chapter has a ton more than anything
we're talking about
so chapter nine
childhood
childhood is a time of exploration it is
a time to learn rules to break rules and
to make new rules
when our older son zach was five years
old he innovated a new mode of
locomotion downstairs which involved a
large rubber ball and a mattress
it worked well until it didn't
his arm break required the surgical
insertion of metal pins to stabilize the
growth plate of his hume
humerus and another surgery six weeks
later to remove them but he healed
beautifully and innovated with more
wisdom going forward
a young orangutan following his mother
through the trees may whimper and call
for her upon reaching a gap that is too
large for him to cross
she will return and bridge the gap
allowing him both to cross and to see
how it is done
young ravens spend years in large social
groups after they become independent
from their parents and before they form
pair bonds with long-term partners
alliances form during this time but
conflicts also arise and those ravens
that figure out how to reconcile with
one another experience less aggression
going forward
when a young snow monkey named imo
innovated cleaning her sweet potatoes by
dipping them into the sea the adults in
her troop were slow to take notice
they lived together on a tiny islet in
japan but only two adults in the troop
copied her behavior over the next five
years
the young monkeys though the other
children and sub-adults watched and
learned
five years on nearly 80 percent of the
juvenile monkeys were cleaning their
sweet potatoes in the style of emo
during childhood we learn how to be
we also learn who we are and we dream
about who we might become
humans are not blank slates but of all
organisms on earth we are the blankest
we have the longest childhoods on earth
and we arrive in the world with more
plasticity than any other species
meaning that we are the least set in
stone
software which is the interplay of
experience and knowledge with capacity
is more important than humans than in
any other species
a profound demonstration of this can be
seen in the peopling of the americas
a handful of ancestors came into the new
world with stoneage technology and
diversified into hundreds of cultures
across two continents inventing writing
astronomy architecture and city-states
along the way the piece the pace of
change being far too rapid to be
attributable to genes it all took place
on the software side
our ability to learn language is part of
our hardware nearly all human babies
have this competence latent in them
which language a baby will speak however
is entirely context dependent that's
software
furthermore we quickly lose some of our
ability to hear and construct the
phonemes and tones of languages that are
not in our environment regardless of our
particular ethnicity or lineage
just as we are born with more neuronal
potential than we use most of our
neurons die off before we become adults
we are also born with linguistic
potential than we use and some of it is
lost during childhood we are born with
broad potential and that potential
narrows over time
on its surface the paring down of
initial capacity may seem like a
tremendous waste so why do we do it
the answer is that when we are born we
are in a mode of exploration
we cannot predict ahead of time
precisely what neurons we will need what
language we will speak so we are born
with a surplus of capacity
this permits us to optimize our minds to
whatever world we find ourselves born
into without the need for prior
knowledge
we are born to explore the world around
us discover its secrets and structure
our minds accordingly
once this job is done we shed our
surplus capacity lest it become a
metabolic liability all cost and no
reward
humans are social with long life spans
and have overlap between generations
grandparents parents and children may
all live in the same place at the same
time
these characteristics also apply to the
other apes to the toothed whales
dolphins and orcas and elephants to
parrots and corvids crows and jays
wolves and lions and more
all species that are social are
long-lived and have generational overlap
also tend to have long childhoods
these other species childhoods come with
tantrums and play emotional depth and
cognitive capacity just like ours
the adults that develop from those
children of other species of social
complexity is recognizable to us humans
as well
spinner dolphins choreograph elaborate
group hunts new caledonian crows share
information among their friends
elephants grieve
spending time as children allows animals
to learn about their environment
therefore stealing childhood from the
young by organizing and scheduling their
play for them by keeping them from risk
and exploration by controlling and
sedating them with screens and
algorithms and legal drugs practically
guarantees that they will arrive at the
age of adulthood without being capable
of actually being adults
all of these actions almost always
well-intentioned prevent the human
software from refining our crude and
rudimentary hardware
absent childhood animals must rely more
fully on hardware and therefore be less
flexible
among migratory bird species those that
are born knowing how when and where to
migrate those that are migrating
entirely with instructions they were
born with
sometimes have wildly inefficient
migration routes
these birds born knowing how to migrate
don't adapt easily
so when lakes dry up forest becomes
farmland or climate change pushes
breeding grounds farther north those
birds that are born knowing how to
migrate keep flying by the old rules and
maps
by comparison birds with the longest
childhoods and those that migrate with
their parents tend to have the most
efficient migration routes
childhood facilitates the passing out of
cultural information and culture can
evolve faster than genes
childhood gives us flexibility in a
changing world
hell yeah so much important there that
um can give you insight into how the
world works why it looks the way it does
and how you might live better if you
know how to extrapolate from it which we
do in that chapter
um yeah it leads me to
a couple of
thoughts one i'm very interested to see
whether the world will figure out
the blankest slant slate point right
that we
so just to reiterate we aren't blankists
we are not blank slates but we are the
blankest of all life on earth right we
are born with the most capacity to
become something we are not yet and so
this puzzle there's a couple layers to
this puzzle one um people will have
heard us talk many times about the fact
that sex is in fact binary whether we
like it or not right it just simply is
um so in this case binary thinking is
actually where you want to start now
there's lots of in the case of sex
sexual cases
right and then you could say actually
the software uh which is gender is much
more variable but the sex isn't right so
there's a binary aspect there's a more
continual aspect with this heavily
bimodal but not perfectly so
or it is bimodal but it is uh if there's
at least uh
stuff from one end of the continuum to
the other that's right but anyway the
point is we tend to be
binary in our thinking reflexively and
that has not served us well with respect
to the um
the so-called nature nurture debate the
uh blank slateism which is preposterous
the rebellion against blank slatism
which is preposterous right both of
these things are wrong and so how do you
even formulate this and just the simple
recognition just the fact the fact that
human beings are just
the blanket slate by virtue of the fact
that the amount of our behavioral
repertoire that has been offloaded to a
flexible uh portion of the mind that is
actually loaded in after we are born
is greater than any other creature
that's an amazing fact and understanding
its implication right and where that
puts us in this non-binary discussion
is crucial so you know i don't know
whether
the book will have this effect on the
discussion but understanding that you
are not being clever to say we are not
blank slates right
if you do not follow it up with
given
that is one end of a continuum and we
are closer to it than anything else then
what are we to infer right exactly and
um
it's not to suggest
that we have any less genetic input at
an absolute level than than our brethren
and than everything else on the planet
um but that we have so much more that
that contributes to us becoming what we
are that you know at the absolute level
we are you know we are genetic um in
makeup just as just as chimps are just
as chanterelle mushrooms are just as
cedars are
just as giraffes are
but we have in addition as you know
and and as with so many of these things
and we talk about this in the book a lot
we've got the sort of nested sets of
like yeah actually all mammals have a
fair bit
of of learning to do and some mammals
don't do very much but because of that
you know initial innovation of milk of
mother's milk which then allows for the
evolution of love and allows for the
transmission not just of you know
nutrients and immunological information
through the actual milk but the tactile
bonding and then the then just the
spending time together that then allows
for the further evolution of more time
that is spent in childhood all mammals
have some some kind of
juvenile phase that could be called
childhood but there are
you know the usual suspects as as i call
them those organisms that are long-lived
and social with generational overlap you
know as as we say in this excerpt i just
read
almost always also tend to have long
childhoods and you know childhood being
that period between birth and um
you know it varies in over in non-human
animal space we tend to say age of first
reproduction um but of course there's a
tremendous amount of time which in
humans we call sort of puberty or
adolescence
after which you are technically capable
of reproducing but before which uh you
are can really be considered a full
adult and so all of that is what work
it's
considering in this concept of childhood
you know during which time different
cultures have
different have different timings and
actually that's the next excerpt that
i'll read maybe that's a good segue but
um all just as just as all mammals
throughout history have provided milk to
their young
all humans throughout history uh have a
period of time during which uh the
children are at first completely
helpless and then somewhat less helpless
and then ever more ability to ever more
able to help themselves but at the same
time
um benefiting from
being in the family setting being
being able to observe what elders do
what youngers do to teach to learn to
interact to play all of these things are
part of
are not an after effect they aren't sort
of what you do and we'll get to this too
they aren't what you do to fill time
because you're stuck in childhood they
are the reason for childhood they are
the reason for childhood and and we
should say
you know it's very easy to jump too
early to a conclusion right so we have
more that is uh divorced from the genes
i didn't mean that um i'm just waiting
for my phone to pick up on the word
divorced and
see
more ads but um
no the the fact that the genes have uh
surrendered control over our behavioral
repertoire is not an indication that the
other part of us has staged a coup and
that's another
key feature of the book is that we
describe the relationship between the
software and the hardware and the point
is they actually agree on the hardware's
objectives for both better and worse
right it makes understanding what we are
much simpler but the point is the genes
have offloaded the work to the software
layer because it has done better and
faster not because they have given up
any control
or they've given up proximate control
but they haven't given up control over
ultimate objectives and that is in many
ways the greatest obstacle that we face
is that we have this sort of default
inherited purpose which is the same as
the purpose of every other creature and
therefore not a worthy purpose for
creatures like us who
have values that are not best matched to
that
you know most fundamental evolutionary
objective
so anyway we have to grapple with that
and i guess the third thing which you
hinted at in passing here
is that childhood
as much as it is an amazing time is
actually an unavoidable cost
in order to get the software part loaded
well
you have to have a childhood it's a cost
that you have to endure and
if you think about the way selection has
to view this childhood is a big risk
right it's because childhood is long and
and dangers are
many
there's every possibility to invest in
someone and have them never reach a
reproductive capacity so it's a cost
that is born because it must be born in
order to get the benefits of it which
are this amazing flexibility right the
difference between being stuck with a
migratory route or being able to change
your migratory route to be more
efficient yeah and i i just i love that
result i remember when i first came up
across that about the migratory birds
that are born knowing where to go and
those that are learning it from their
parents on the fly quite literally um i
i used to share that um in my vertebrae
evolution programs and i when i taught
that and
you know i've seen i've seen the update
but i've it also you know stands it
hasn't been falsified this
this idea that even for birds traveling
long distances
um if you have someone
with whom you can do an interplay
in real time go like oh this or that
this or that as opposed to i know what
to do and i'm doing it how how would you
learn under those conditions it's got to
be a very very drastic change for a
migratory bird who's born knowing is
born with the instructions on board for
where to go and how to get there uh to
change that up right it's it's the very
clumsy process that we describe in the
bio 101 textbook rather than the
upgraded process that selection has
discovered that allows for the rapid
honing in on a new innovative way of
doing something better well and then
yeah
yeah don't get us started on textbooks
right like in in this is in so many
things what's in the textbook is
um
[Music]
hopefully was generally thought to be
right at the point that it was written
uh it never describes the actual process
by which we arrive at what we think to
be true that is it doesn't describe the
actual scientific process it may
describe the conclusions of the
scientific process
and it doesn't it tends to
simplify to the point of caricature
which often then ends up introducing
inaccuracy
usually unintentional um but you know so
often textbook versions of things as
opposed to
deep dives and discussions about what
the implications are will lead you
astray and this is you know this is this
is why this is sort of the basis for
this
thing that people say you know a little
knowledge can be a bad thing right you
know you know a little bit and you think
you know
you think you know what evolution is you
think you know what science is and then
you speak with the authority from a
textbook as opposed to the authority of
having dug deep and tried to think
through
what would this mean what are the
implications if a b and c then what what
will follow and that of course is a
large part of what we're trying to do
here and
yeah evolutionary lens i mean i've i've
changed my opinion a little bit on
what's going on in the textbooks i mean
textbooks themselves are a troubling
phenomenon and let me just say school is
next week so we'll get we'll come back
here we'll get there yeah but
if you think about just the process of
science and textbooks as sort of a um an
instantaneous description of the model
as it stands right they're not perfect
they're written
so as to be understood they're not
necessarily the top quality thinking
they should lean in that direction as
often as possible but if you think about
science as a process that builds models
that predict behavior of stuff
and those models as they get closer and
closer to the truth predict better and
better right the number of factors that
they exclude drops the textbook in
theory should grow
and its ability to predict what takes
place in any particular instance should
go up but at some level this is not so
different from the much more normal
process of understanding the world
around you whether it be the social
world or whether it be the sport that
you play or or whatever you know you
have some model something you you say
that isn't exactly true right and so in
the book we talk about literally false
metaphorically true things but the
degree to which that applies to every
realm
right in sport for example um the idea
that you have to follow through right on
your swing at the baseball
yeah right you're not affecting the
baseball after it has left the bat
following through is not what works it's
the planning to follow through that
causes you to hit the baseball properly
and then everything after that is just
what happens right
so
does that matter no the best way to
teach somebody to hit the baseball
properly is to tell them to follow
through right
yeah i remember this um
i played more tennis than baseball as a
kid even before this foot surgery that i
had um
and i remember
in a stubborn moment which i had a few
of like what if i don't what if i don't
follow through
and um
and i i could just tell i could just
tell as a kid there's no way i
understand the physics well enough i
have scientifically informed people in
my life and even though i'm a kid i know
that this can't matter
but i couldn't if i knew i wasn't
following through i could not play as
effective tennis as if i didn't think it
and part of it is that part of it is
that um you can reach that
sort of flow state more easily if you
aren't trying to stop the thing as soon
as as soon as you leave as soon as the
rack the ball leaves the racket right
right that's part of it but it's also
that
there's actually in order to stop the
racket afterwards you have to invest in
the stopping of it and that gets in the
road of the thing that you're doing so
imagining the follow-through actually
matters it does matter but it doesn't
matter for the advertised reason right
obviously anybody anybody who plays one
of these things can figure that out but
um but the point is no it's still the
best way to teach it and you know how do
you figure out what's going to happen on
a billiard table right well newtonian
mechanics is wrong but it's not so wrong
that we don't still teach it because
it's still really freaking useful at
slow speeds right
so anyway
these are models they contain a degree
so just just to fill that out you're not
you don't teach einstein to people
learning pool right right it does it
would be that would be pointless right
it would be pointless yeah right if
you're if you're trying to understand
what's going to happen the the added
value of doing it uh the more rigorous
way is not matched by the added
complication of it and so you have this
approximate model that works really well
[Music]